i appreciated uh perry when uh taylor
hawkins died you did a very beautiful
tribute i had no idea how close you were
with taylor from the foo fighters the
drummer well you talk about a guy who
brought people together to make music
when you were saying that i was just
thinking about taylor he was that guy
he was the guy who brought people
together he brought musicians together
he loved music he loved making music and
writing songs
you know we are all kindred spirits
songwriters john lennon was a songwriter
you know billy corgan's a songwriter he
sure is
and so was taylor taylor loved to write
music and write songs
yeah there's the moments in time where
you kind of have to stop you know we our
lives are pretty fast and that's one of
those times where you kind of have to
stop and think about it for a couple
days you know because it affects so many
people so deeply not only his fans and
of course his family but
you know it all gives us pause you know
do you ever go surfing with uh taylor oh
yeah we would just go on surf trips and
he would say to me he goes you know what
makes us different pear
we surf
he goes that's what separates us from
the other guys don't ever give up
surfing he loved surfing so much he
wasn't the greatest surfer but he was
very courageous
and the courage went into the music